is prime protein, I grabbed a pitcher off the web here,
a grass-fed beef isolate protein,
made with coconut milk, powder,
beet juice, and stevia, a good protein choice.
I looked up, yeah, and this is a good protein choice.
You have this?
Yes, absolutely.
You can use this product, that's just fine.
However, even this product,
I think it's like 22 grams of protein.
You really want to get how many grams of protein
you want to really stimulate your immune system.
I don't know.
Well, the answer is you want to get
an equal amount of grams of protein
as you're weight in cones.
So, if I weigh 200 pounds,
you want to eat 200 grams of protein a day.
It doesn't make any sense to be taking
that much protein powder.
So, you think about getting some chicken
or good source beef and good salmon,
and you can certainly Google a document.
Maybe I could find one and put it up on the,
maybe I did, I think, I don't know if I did.
I'm a blog post that I described this information,
but so, certainly don't want to be taking it all
an protein powder, but this is great.
I use it a protein powder is,
you can gain 20 grams, 25 grams protein
by throwing that in your smoothie,
and it's another good way to get stuff in.
So.